so ferry's blown you up a few times and
now you want to be the one blowing
people up here are some tips for Farah
how to get started what strategies you
want to use to succeed in overwatch
Chris waters here with Danny O'Dwyer
Danny let's start with the basics what
is Farah dude
Farah is basically the sort of Team
Fortress 2 soldier of this video game
she is the rocket launcher class is the
sort of easiest way of putting it as
she's all about hassling the
opposition's is all about dealing damage
on you know individuals and on groups as
well and killing people quick and
getting the hell out of there yeah that
rocket has Splash Damage so you don't
have to hit the person directly you can
hit something near them or you can hit
groups so you just want to be throwing
those rockets in there and the best
place to do that is from on hot yeah for
sure in fact positioning is basically
the most important thing with our
abilities as you said rocket launcher
basically just shoots our Rockets at a
pretty steady rate she also has a
concussive blast which does deal damage
but is mostly used for disrupting people
you know knocking snipers off of their
positions and sort of splitting groups
apart as well and it's also really good
for using against shields cuz it does
quite a lot of damage against those so
if that there's a Reinhardt Colin Archer
for instance are really good to use that
there yeah if someone's charging in at
you if someone's becoming real close you
push them back and that's one of the
things about overwatch is positioning is
huge and concussive blast also a fun way
to push people off a Ledge if you can
swing it yeah if they're quite close to
it it's always a real treat to try and
lock them all Errol to rocket barrage
real good for taking out groups of
people especially if you're standing
right above them I mean positioning for
that one's really important making sure
there's not like a sniper around making
sure there's not a turret around as well
you can get a group of people maybe on
the point unleash your alts though
serious damage yeah and it recharges
fairly quickly it's one of the faster
ones so use it often one of the
trickiest ferrah alts I got was someone
just came in a doorway like three
million my teammates were in a room she
blew us all up
but yeah big damage and combos really
well with something like sorry assaults
you know look for opportunities for
people in groups
blow yeah when it comes to far like
physician as everything get in the air
make sure that you are using rooftops
for resting that you're not stuck sort
of with Jim pop in the middle of the
fight because you're going to get
yourself talked a lot more there as
she's also useful for flanking so if you
can find a sort of an odd way around the
map to maybe take out a turret that's
hanging out back there or Widowmaker
especially snipers and you should really
be attacking in fact if there is a
bastion on that map and you're Farah you
need that is your responsibility you
need to be blowing up fashion you need
to blow up Torbjorn turrets yeah and yet
don't forget about the hover you can use
your jetpack to like get on ledges it
doesn't always have to be the jump jet
that launches use directly into the air
hovering is a great way to maneuver
around the map and be careful a
temptation is just to sort of sit up in
the sky and rain down it's a great way
to get yourself sniped
so again mobility is key with Farah pop
up pop back down pop up pop back down
exactly I mean you can take out
widow-makers on turrets with far really
easily you can just as easily make
yourself an easy target for those people
if you launch up in the air too early if
you're going after Widowmaker don't jump
and fly the water jump once you're a
four feet because she's gonna have a
really hard time looking up with a
slider scope to try and take you out
even that's how you basically do that
and that's a really important sort of
aspect for her I mean the other thing is
to focus fire on tanks as much as
possible the thing would fire is she can
shoot really really high damage from
quite far away so you can stay back you
don't need to be the front of the pack
you can stay back and as long as you've
got eyes on the melee that's there just
keep lobbing rockets in there over and
over and then change position because
they know where you're you know Mercy's
got the angel wings but picture yourself
like the guardian angel of your team
just sort of hovering around the
shoulders popping up here and there
blowing people to smithereens and you'll
be well on your way to playing a solid
Pharaoh for sure and I guess the last
big tip for me is when you're on maps
that are you know they've got a point a
lot of those are internal with buildings
with quite high ceilings jump up there
use the right-click to float around and
if you can you know get justice terrain
from above in those situations you're
onto a winner
you might get yourself a play league a
play the games come pretty frequently
refer have fun playing Farah folks and
stay tuned the game spot for more of our
overwatch tips
first round one